You have something I want.
you may think
you have some idea what you're in
possession of but you do not
Are you ready for round two?
We need to talk.
The enthusiasm is infectious
everyone is coming with their own
experiences to a galaxy that can support
it and I also have a group of filmmakers
who were not afraid to jump in
It's hard to believe all these years
later there's such energy around new
stories in this world.
The volume put me
back in a set as if it was built the
outside is all video walls in the top is
a video wall.
That was for me one of the
most rewarding experiences that someone
who just loves Star Wars.
It was like one
of the weirdest and best things that
ever happened with Werner, he was acting
against the baby and he started
directing the baby directly I'm trying
to direct Werner who's now directing the
puppet he was telling us we needed to
commit to the magic make them use the
puppet
IG 11 was like ig-88 they built him out
of parts of the old Cantina set from a
new hope, we as children like that's the
coolest assassin robot it was bolted to
the floor we're trying to draw from all
over Star Wars
Sometimes I think it's just like
anything in any different seem you just
have energy and you can see that in the
physicality you can see that in the acting
George reiterated remember to make these
stories hopeful to give that to kids
because they really need it it's
important to the foundation of Star Wars
but we don't just want an action we want
to feel uplifted and Star Wars
ultimately is about family it is really
saying there is a lot of hope out there.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Mandalorian season
two teaser video we also have a trailer
for the other Mandalorian spinoff series
they also made a bunch of announcements
about other Star Wars live-action series
so we'll break it all down if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we're doing an Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
Mandalorian moment on the video I know
everyone's desperately in need for some
good news right now because of
everything that's going on in the world
with the virus well there is a lot of
good news packed into all this just
going down the list starting with number
five the Mandalorian season 2 teaser
just mostly hyping up more space battles
in the Razr crest more time developing
the dynamic between the Mandalorian baby
Yoda as he collects more bounties
earning more money for repairs and also
tracking down the Jedi that survived the
purge he will be as your son until you
find these enemy sorcerers to help train
him recently we obviously learned that
one of those former Jedi would be ahsoka
tano played by rosario Dawson we don't
know exactly what she's going to look
like in the live-action series they
haven't released an official preview of
her character but there's been a ton of
brand-new fan art since the announcement
and some of these are probably really
close to what she's actually going to
look like they'll probably just paint
her face to match Ahsoka's skin tone
just like they paint Gamora green for
guardians of the galaxy and then some
combination of prosthetics and special
effects to get the rest of a sokka's
head shape right with the tails there's
no way they're going to be able to do
action scenes and keep all that as a
practical effect even when they film
with the puppet version of baby Yoda
they said that they still have to tune
him up with special effects to make his
face more expressive the eyes the way
his mouth in his ears move if you watch
baby Yoda when he's watching the mando
anytime he gets scared or happy you can
see him using his ears to express
emotion most of that they can do with
the puppet but then they have to sweeten
it just a little bit so that it pops
on-screen with special effects baby Yoda
is just a really good example for this
because sometimes baby Yoda is full CG
like this scene when he's forced choking
cardoon sometimes he's a physical puppet
and the actors can pick him up and walk
around with him in sometimes he's a
combination of the two so for the most
part ahsoka is going to be practical
with a little
special effects to make her pop a little
more on screen I think the only time
they would go for a full CG ahsoka as if
she gives some super crazy lightsaber
fight with moth Gideon in the dark saber
Giancarlo Esposito who plays moth Gideon
has been talking about all the crazy
dark saber lightsaber battles that he
has he didn't say who he's fighting but
he said some of his dark saber
lightsaber battles are so hardcore that
he breaks the dark saber props over and
over again for next big thing they just
announced another brand new Star Wars
live-action series is coming to Disney
Plus in the next few years and it's
separate from all the brand-new ones
that we just heard about a couple months
ago they didn't say what the title would
be only that it would be set during a
very different part of the timeline from
all the other live-action Star Wars
series that have already been announced
so that confirms that it's not the
ahsoka spin-off series that we heard
about a few weeks ago this new series
sounds like it could either be something
during Knights of the Old Republic era
or during the High Republic era that new
part of the timeline between 400 and 200
years ago before the original trilogy
that Lucasfilm is developing for all the
books and the comics stuff right now
post all your predictions in the
comments though if it's going to be set
during a vastly different part of the
timeline and not overlap with the other
series when is this new series going to
be set because you either go into the
distant past or you go into the future
and we just went into the future with
the new trilogy so I think they're kind
of trying to avoid that period number
three the ahsoka series that is
reportedly being planned would be set
closer to present-day because it would
be Rosario Dawson's ahsoka they haven't
said anything about bringing other Star
Wars rebels or Clone Wars characters to
the live-action series but some of you
have been asking me about all the other
Mandalorian characters from the other
series like Sabine Wren Ezra Bridger Bo
Catan any of those characters would be
fair game for the Mandalorian main
series in the next couple of seasons or
even the ahsoka spin-off series in in
addition to the ahsoka spin-off series
there are reports that Rosario Dawson's
contract allows her to guest star on the
other live-action Star Wars series
they'd have to be series set when ahsoka
is a little bit older obviously you
couldn't do a little kid ahsoka without
recasting a completely different actress
even though a sokka's relationship with
obi-wan Kenobi is very strained if
anyone's been watching the last couple
of episodes of Clone Wars it's pretty
evident she could cross over to the
live-action obi-wan
Cirie's we just said after the events of
Revenge of the Sith but before a new
hope we don't really know much about the
other Mandalorian spinoff serious that
closer to present-day except for the new
documentary series but the Disney CEO
did confirm they have multiple
Mandalorian spin-offs in development so
number two that other trailer at the
beginning of this video with all the
footage of Jon Favreau and the other
Star Wars Mandalorian directors is
actually for a Mandalorian spin-off
series that's premiering May the 4th as
the trailer said may the 4th be with you
they're meant to be special bonus
Mandalorian episodes after season 1
maybe with a little season 2 stuff
teased in there too the episodes will be
around the same length as the regular
Mandalorian season 1 episodes but if you
remember when HBO did the game revealed
episodes for Game of Thrones season 6
season 7 season 8 the last couple of
years this will be Star Wars doing a
slightly different version of that it's
more like a documentary series it'll run
eight episodes total and each of the
episodes will cover something different
fund Amanda Lawrence series I will be
doing videos for that series it's going to
drop the same day the Clone Wars season
7 finale drops the siege of Mandalore
and I will also be doing videos for the
final Clone Wars episodes and speaking
of Mandalorians number 1 while we were
just getting started with all this new
Mandalorian season 2 stuff is coming
later this year the Star Wars people
also confirmed that the Mandalorian
season 3 has already started
pre-production right now that means that
they must have stealth renewed it for
multiple seasons last year because Jon
Favreau has already been working on the
Mandalorian season 3 episodes scripts
since last year that just means that
they'll be able to avoid any huge delays
between season 2 and season 3 episodes
so unless they tell us otherwise just
expect the Mandalorian season 3 episodes
to be on the same release schedule as
the season 2 episodes and season 2
starts in October this year it's a
little too early to speculate on what
the story of Mandalorian season 3 is
going to be before we see any of the season
2 episodes but since the series leans so
hard on original trilogy references and
because Giancarlo Esposito keeps hyping
up his scenes with baby Yoda I'm kind of
hoping that they go for the Empire
Strikes Back
season 2 downer ending where Moff Gideon
is able to take baby Yoda from the mando
and then the beginning of season 3 is
kind of like the beginning of Return of
the Jedi with
no putting a team together to rescue him
but post all your Mandalorian season
three predictions in the comments below
too so if you have any special requests
just let me know in the comments below
there were a bunch of big trailers and
teasers that drop the past couple of
days a lot of really good news so I'll
try to make videos for all that stuff as
long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see all those videos
when I post them but everyone click here
for all my Mandalorian episodes and
click here for my brand new spider-man 3
Tom Holland video thank you so much for
watching everyone stays safe this is the
way!